je prépare un petit panier voyez avec
beaucoup de statistiques mais beaucoup
de blé et beaucoup de bleu et blanc
ce sont vraiment des couleurs très
tendance cette année
bienvenue dans l'atelier de martin ici
il ya des fleurs séchées
partout des immortels bien sur des
chardons de la lavande depuis bientôt 30
ans elle fait pousser des fleurs les
récoltes et les fait sécher pour créer
des compositions
ce que j'adore aussi cette fleur là en
général du mais les fleurs que j'aime
bien
depuis quelques années elle conçoit des
objets de décoration toujours à base de
fleurs séchées et lee ajoute dubois
transforme des bouteilles en plastique
bref elle crée car voilà pour faire
vivre son commerce il a fallu
diversifier la gamme des produits
proposés
nos clients sont très fidèles et
franchement ils viennent de tours de
bourges de reboise de partout et il faut
vraiment vraiment les garder tous ses
clients
il faut toujours qu'on leur propose des
nouveautés il faut qu'ils viennent qui
rentre on leur dise ça c'est nouveau ça
c'est nouveau il faut vraiment être la
halle attentes de nos clients et c'est
encore plus vrai en ce moment avec les
achats de noël
la période est importante très
importante même la commerçante réalisant
quatre semaines 50 % de son chiffre
d'affaires
voyez donc toutes mes dernières
créations mêlant peu voyez celui ci
c'est un coquelicot qui voulait faire en
fleurs stabiliser tout est prêt parce
que pour les fêtes de noël ce pour nous
c'est très important et c'est vraiment
des périodes qu'il faut surtout pas
louper pour attirer les clients et les
faire revenir la créatrice commerçante
ne laisse rien au hasard
elle a aussi pensé à la décoration
extérieure